the world is changing fast
how should the european union evolve to
face new challenges
what would strengthen its democracy and
make it fit for the coming decades
what about the economy the environment
our health your views count the european
parliament has laid the foundations of
the conference on the future of europe
alongside the european commission
and eu countries
the conference which was delayed by the
pandemic will begin soon
at the heart of the conference will be
you europe's citizens
and civil society representing your
interests
on the ground at local regional national
and european levels
people will be able to debate discuss
and share ideas in citizen panels
while anyone can participate young
people especially are encouraged to give
their feedback through digital platforms
and events
such as the european youth event in
strasbourg
the conference will be chaired by the
presidents of the european parliament
the council and the commission when the
conference reports its conclusions in
spring 2022
parliament will use the findings to push
for an eu which has the priorities of
europeans at its heart
and is ready to address their concerns